and now i shall proceed to induct into
office
our 15th president dr charles marsteller
vest
may you serve the institute and dignify
its office of president with all the
skill
wisdom and dedication
which our confidence accords to you
and may your administration be memorable
a journey that began in a warm family in
a small town in west virginia
has led to center stage in killian court
where my own path and that of the
institute
have come together in this symbolic
moment
what then is my vision of mit a decade
hence
mit will be a preeminent wellspring of
scientific knowledge and technological
innovation
mit will better reflect in our students
our faculty and our staff
the changing face of america
mit will spearhead efforts to rekindle
our nation's belief
in the importance of scientific research
and education
mit will stand for integrity in all that
it does
mit will serve our nation well
but also will be of and for the greater
world community
it was chuck who figured out how to
renew our partnerships with government
and industry by leading the charge
nationally in promoting a new kind of
partnership between government industry
and the university
chuck is probably the best connected
scientist and university representative
in washington what i tried to do was to
simply spend a lot of time in washington
talking to anybody who would listen
whether it was principals in congress or
staff or
executive offices agencies
and just to try to deliver the very
simple message
that this partnership between our public
and private universities and the federal
government was extremely important to
the future of our economy health
security quality of life
it takes time to
understand the depth of his of his
knowledge of his persistence of his
vision
and so he works at it it's it's not
it's not one visit and the jobs done
it's dozens of visits and hundreds of
visits these are the kinds of young men
and young women in whom we
through the federal government
must invest
if we are going to embrace excellence
rather than mediocrity
he stepped up to the plate to actually
chair our first national innovation
summit at mit in 1998. now it is a
distinct pleasure and privilege to
welcome the senior senator from the
commonwealth of massachusetts senator
edward m kennedy
his voice has been heard but it's a
quiet voice but it's an insistent and an
informed voice and i think that's why
it's been heard so clearly chuck vest is
a long time friend and the vice
president the president listened and i
think that underscores that it's not
just his
understanding of these issues but he
changes policy
he sounded the theme of the importance
of student life and learning
during chuck's tenure of president we've
seen a major transformation of the
residential life system we've seen new
buildings and new facilities
but i think even deeper than that is the
renewed emphasis mit has placed on the
residential system
as the underpinning for student
community
the zesger sports and fitness center
it's been the best investment dollar for
dollar brick for brick glass pain for
glass pain chuck could have made
i love the facilities here i'm here like
every day
the health and fitness level of the
whole campus has changed
we wanted to study the problem very
systematically collect data and see if
we could make the case clearly to the
dean of what was going on
reports like this were gathering dust in
many universities so the difference was
why did this president
have the courage to say this what i said
was approximately this i said i've
always believed that
gender bias in universities is part
perception and part reality and from
this report
i've learned that it's mostly reality
and this comment you know when i saw it
i knew how deeply chuck understood what
this was all about and i just cried you
know because i couldn't believe that
this president of this university any
university would come to understand that
this was true and would say so there
were a couple of days in which nancy and
i
were literally getting a thousand or so
messages a day i've never ever
experienced anything like this they came
from first from all over the country
universities then they started coming
from
researchers and
companies
then they started coming from overseas
and they all said the same thing this is
my story that was a really brilliant
moment in uh the progress of women in
academia just a fabulous moment many
universities women tell me they were
called in by the chairman said now i
want you to know this has nothing to do
with the mit study but we're giving you
an enormous raise
and
so many people have told me this
in this job
you must be
a politician fundraiser budget cutter
salary raiser spiritual confessor
negotiator diplomat parental substitute
guardian of public safety provider of
wholesome and tasty dormitory meals
dedicated researcher conservator of
age-old values politically correct and
hip leader director of big time
athletics woody spokesperson to the
press expert on all things humble
servant charismatic leader eloquent
speaker sophisticated host example of
physical fitness literary critic
scientist historian arbiter of musical
taste
investment guru friend of the city
council
towering public figure
and just one of the gang
for ocw to have succeeded it had to have
great leadership from on high
this was not a project for the timid
he thought it was a good way for mit to
move forward its agenda of influencing
and benefiting society
and so he advocated for it he committed
the institution for it he helped raise
the money for it if you look back over
the period of this campaign
when we started it
there was no data center
there was no brain and cognitive science
project there was no mcgovern institute
for brain research there was no pick our
center for learning and memory there was
no broad institute for genomic medicine
excellence can't be bought
but it has to be paid for
you know you always when you go on a
river rafting trip you see where someone
else is going
if you're not sure of yourself and chuck
was one of the guys who always led the
way through the white water and when we
saw what he was doing we followed
the courage and the wisdom he
demonstrated time and again in tackling
and helping to solve some of the
thorniest most controversial problems in
higher education has made him the most
influential university president in this
country for the past 10 years or more
some successful leaders are transient
leaders after their time is over their
accomplishments cannot be carried
forward
other leaders are legacy leaders what
they accomplish during their very
successful tenure
becomes a foundation for the next
generation
chuck is definitely a legacy leader
faculty at mit not only respect chuck
and his ability to listen to competing
arguments but they also actually like
him
and to be a college president for 14
years and to still be respected and
liked by the vast majority of faculty
it's just an extraordinary achievement
14 classes of mit students among others
can hold up their diplomas with pride
and say that this degree means more than
just a technical education
it represents the embodiment of a
crucial lesson taught to us by our
president
about what integrity will and courage
should mean to anyone who claims to be a
world-class leader
but above all we want you to understand
that in the deepest way possible
that the world is not something that
just happens to you
the world is something that you can
shape and contribute to mightily
you